Okay, so here I am on the Twilio signup page. Oh, by the way,
this link, its also available in the instructor notes. Here I will signup for
free. Twilio also wants my phone number,
which I will provide. Now, I'm currently
located in the United States. Make sure
you select the country where you are located.
Then Twilio sends me a verification code on the phone that
I had previously registered, you will get one on your phone
too. I will enter that code in this box here. Okay,
so they're giving me a phone number, I'm not quite sure
I understand that just yet, but I will go ahead and
continue. Alright, it seems like I can do a bunch of
things here with my account, but I'm really looking for my
authorization token. Where is that? Hm? Let me just go to
my account. ha! Here they are. Here's the Account SID, and here in the
Authorization Token. Now, I'm going to copy
and paste both of these into my program.